Georgia melón y la líder de la
ultraderecha Italiana presentó su
programa de gobierno Este martes un
programa cuya principal prioridad será
la lucha contra la inflación la crisis
energética generada por la guerra en
Ucrania y el riesgo de una recesión en
la tercera economía de la zona Euro
melón y prometió ayudas estatales a
familias y empresas italianas para
reducir el impacto del aumento de Los
costos del gas de la electricidad y del
precio de la gasolina también garantizó
reducciones de impuestos y hasta una
amnistía fiscal para reactivar el
crecimiento de la economía italiana
anunció una serie de reformas del
sistema fiscal de la educación y la
justicia también abordó los asuntos de
política internacional reiteró el apoyo
de Italia a Ucrania y a la otan prometió
luchar contra la inmigración clandestina
dijo que pedirá la Unión Europea que se
impidan las salidas de los barcos con
migrantes desde el norte de África por
otro lado afirmó su voluntad de
solicitar modificaciones a las
condiciones del fondo de recuperación
europeo recordemos Italia es el estado
que más dinero europeo va a recibir en
los próximos años unos 200.000 millones
de euros en préstamos y subvenciones
otorgados a Italia por la Unión Europea
una Unión que Italia no pretende frenar
o sabotear dijo melón y sino conducirla
hacia una mayor eficacia Italia hará oír
su voz en Europa advirtió Georgia meloni
en este su primer discurso programático
ante la cámara de diputados del
parlamento italiano desde el inicio de
su mandato como jefe del gobierno Italia